SPEAKER: What's up, everyone?
Thanks for checking out "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Navigating the
Cloud can be tricky.
So we want to make sure
you have all the tools you
need to succeed.
First up, we're hosting an
instructor-led training session
to help you get the
fundamentals together.
This class will
give you an overview
of some of the most popular
Google Cloud solutions
through presentations,
demos, and hands-on labs.
Come learn with us.
Of course, if you're not in
the area or you can't make it,
you can also check out the
fundamentals or other courses
on Coursera.
This is a great tool
for self-paced learning,
and you still get a
try running the code
with hands-on tutorials.
There are tons of courses that
can help you learn and get
certified.
So find the right
content for you.
Now, once you know
the fundamentals,
you'll probably want to try
running some jobs in the Cloud.
Google Cloud Composer
is a managed version
of Apache Airflow
that automatically
scales to run your workflows.
We've just launched
a solution article
to help you get a
better understanding,
run a sample workflow that
backs up virtual machines,
and it gets you ready to start
customizing your own jobs.
Try it out for yourself
and see what you can build.
Now, again, if what you're
trying to build needs
security-- and spoiler
alert, it probably does--
and you want to manage the
cryptographic keys yourself,
there are also some new client
libraries and code samples
for you to get started from.
The Cloud Key Management
Service gives you
control of your encryption
and integrates into our Cloud
Identity suite, letting
you more easily build
secure applications.
Check out the new samples and
use the new client libraries
to secure your apps.
And if your apps
use speech-to-text
or text-to-speech,
we're excited to share
that we've rolled out some great
updates, more features, more
voices, more languages, better
accuracy, and lower prices.
If you've been interested
in trying these out,
there's no better time than now.
So check out how we've
made our models better,
then try them out for yourself.
And don't forget,
the first 60 minutes
of audio you process every month
with speech-to-text is free.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.